Dada Dada Dada Dada right there
okay oh wait no makes get back here one
of us is the murderer you have to choose
it must be Gandil
we so all of you guys found someone
[ __ ] crazy we never liked doing stuff
in the background and I did
it's the matter it's the Matt can
someone explain really quick how are you
play okay so one person has the gun oh
yeah uh-huh yes so you're not I have to
say if you have the gun from now on okay
it's not me wall of bulletproof
manliness I am just gonna go into the
house alive right I'll - okay cuz I am
innocent bystander me three four that's
all okay so floor no I know get away
from me I can't I'm too fat you have the
knife I
I think come back here you little scamp
I said I drop my weight all right there
we go okay what do you doing with that
gun slave self strange skills what you
gonna do huh balcony yeah no it's my
balcony I came up here to be alone throw
your knife at somebody no no let's all
jump on three Oh jump off okay ready one
two hey Trix [ __ ] whoa what are you
doing with that hello I'm just giving
you some sweet-ass furniture man in mrs.
space take a check take a check
sit down everyone like me cuz I just
showed up was that it was it like your
dance well action I'm trying I can't
really well oh my god hey I got this
wait which one of you which was thank
you who what where are you I don't know
where are you sobbing what is how I am
totally innocent
I have you shoot me you'll be killing
your last friend here okay oh my friend
come on if you're my friend then give me
a hug murder no no no Holmes the
murderer would say that right now what
always being very murderous let him go
eeny Meeny bunny
who's that go whoa set on my Shack I'll
share my share with you sharing I shall
share with you it's very sharing of you
to share your share I know all right who
just knives
it wasn't Papa I didn't see I heard
something it's really weird so weird
damn its bugged I think mark just died
on protect us I'm trying to protect you
guys
oh it's probably minx I'm just gonna say
the right house from ya
what you gonna do huh way to kill
everyone huh hey way to go huh well I
guess now we know who it is
[Music]
there's a murderer on the loose how do
you hear that that's a very murderer
thing to say why would you bring up
murder why would you bring that up I
just read it why would you talk about
murder right now ready on reddit reddit
is a place where murder is often hangout
I've heard hey hey you want a shower
no I'm going for a swim they're gonna
pool yeah Wow Wow it's on it's on well
then it's mark why don't you kill me
before because I wanted to play the long
game yeah I hear there's rain coming are
we gonna do anything man um again I can
you want me to calm down
hey meenie miney mo homewrecker
he's gotta get shot in the face what
five hundred percent on a crazy face oh
god oh god what am i doing